friendship family and fun what do these
words have in common they're integral
parts of the human experience and also
share the same first letter our
ancestors thousands of years in the past
may have struggled to pronounce these
words as the sound would have been
cumbersome to produce sounds like or are
called labial dentals labia relating to
your lips and dentals your teeth they
are produced when you raise your bottom
lip to touch your upper teeth labia
dentals are used in over half of the
languages spoken around the world today
but before shifts and food processing
technology these sounds may not have
been as common before the Neolithic food
was minimally processed and required
more effort to chew this constant
gnashing meant teeth wore down more
resulting in what is known as an edge to
edge bite by adolescence
then came the emergence of food
processing technologies gone were the
days of laborious chewing as stews
preserved foods and ground grayness
flour became more common softer food
meant less wear and tear on the teeth
and the preservation of an overbite a
vertical overlap of the teeth and an
over jet horizontal overlapping of the
teeth which humans are normally born
with researchers created a biomechanical
model of an edge to edge bite align top
and bottom teeth and an over Jen and
overbite to see if one provided an
advantage for articulating lay vo
dentals they found that the edge to edge
configuration would have required more
effort to produce a labia Dental as the
distance from the bottom lip and top
teeth would have been greater the
preservation of an overbite and overjet
also increased the likelihood that a
labia Dental would be made on accident
like saying instead of
today nearly all societies have access
to softer foods and most people retain
their overbite and overjet throughout
their lifetimes
this makes producing labiodental is
easier but historically not all
languages have had these sounds nowadays
many languages are acquiring lay do
dental sounds like and through contact
with other languages that have them one
example includes West Greenlandic
speakers who have been in long sustained
contact with European languages
including Danish this study shows how
language can be shaped by changes in
human biology in the future researchers
hope to better understand not only how
this language change took place but why
some data suggests that labial dental
served as an indicator of social class
proving advantageous to those who
adopted the sound in the meantime thank
your local food processor for being able
to say those F words
you